لا هدوء في قصر بوكيهم فما كادت الضجه ان
تهدا من الحلقات الاولى لمسلسل هاري وماجد
حتى اطلقت المنصه حلقات ثلاث اخرى تضيء
هذه الحلقات على الخلافات بين الشقيقين
اللدودين هاري وليم وبين هاري والملك
ترانس ايضا وهي تواصل سرد اسرار القصر
الاشهر في بريطانيا
كما يتحدث عما يصفها باللعبه القذره بين
القصر والاعلام فهل يتهم القصر بمقايضه
قصه سلبيه لا يريدها بقصه سلبيه اخرى
[موسيقى]
اساليبه هل يشير ايضا الى غيره بعض افراد
العائله من
ماجدتها وكيف ان العائله الملكيه لم تسمح
لها بالحصول على المساعده خشيه ان يؤثر
ذلك على صوره المؤسسه الملكيه
اتهامات عديده وجهها ثنائيهاري وماجين
للعائله الملكيه تجعل من مهمه ترميم
العلاقه بينهما شبه مستحيله في المقابل لا
تتوقف وسائل الاعلام عن الهجوم على ثنائي
ربما بالوكاله عن العائله ورغم ان
الاحصاءات تشير الى نسب مشاهده عاليه
للمسلسل تشير احصاءات اخرى الى ان شعبيه
هاري وماجن هي الادنى بين افراد العائله
الملكيه من لندن لصباح العربيه عروب عبد
الحق